you
you
hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar testosterone testing
turtle free and bioavailable I am
Kristen present II love lab routes and
I'll be moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab routes the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
made possible by an open educational
grant from agilent technologies agilent
technologies has had no input in the
selection of speakers content or mode of
presentation let's get started you can
pose questions to the speaker during a
presentation while they're fresh in your
mind to do so simply type them into the
Q&A box which will open when you click
the green Q&A button at the lower left
of the presentation window questions
will be answered after the presentation
to enlarge the slide window click on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support button found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
green Q&A button at lower left this is
an educational webinar and thus offers
free continuing education credits after
the webinar is over please click on the
CD button located in the bottom
left-hand corner of your webpage and
follow the process of obtaining your
credit I now present today's speaker dr.
u Shinju dr. Zhu is professor and
medical director of clinical chemistry
co-director of automated testing
laboratory and pathology core reference
laboratory and director of post doctoral
clinical chemistry fellowship program at
Penn State University Hershey Medical
Center prior to this position he served
as a tenured professor and medical
director of clinical chemistry and
toxicology director of post doctoral
clinical chemistry fellowship program at
the Medical University of South Carolina
for over ten years he is board certified
by the American Board of clinical
chemistry in clinical chemistry talks to
logic toxicology chemistry and molecular
diagnostics and a fellow of the National
Academy
clinical biochemistry since 2007 he
served as the president of the North
American Chinese clinical chemistry
sociation in 2012 president of the
Commission on Accreditation in clinical
chemistry chair of American Association
for clinical chemistry southeast section
in 2015
chair of clinical translational science
division 2015 to 2016 and secretary of
proteomics and metabolomics division in
2013 to 2015 of AACC currently he is the
board director of a DCC treasurer of
mass spectrometry and separation science
division and serves on global laboratory
quality initiative asia-pacific working
group and mass spectometry conference
organizing committee of AACC mission is
on the editorial boards of three medical
journals and an invited reviewer of
seven international medical journals he
has given many presentations at national
and international conferences he is
interested in clinical and translational
research in clinical chemistry
toxicology evil globin apathy
pharmacogenetic kinetics proteomics and
clinical application of mass
spectrometry he has over 100
publications including peer reviewed
reviewed papers editorials book chapters
and abstracts he has research received
31 awards from AACC and AC B and other
organizations dr. Z will now begin his
presentation good morning sent Kristin
for your introduction and thank you all
for attending this webinar today I will
talk about testosterone testing total
three and the power variable right
number
this is the outline of my talk first of
all we will briefly review
pathophysiology of testosterone then I
will introduce current methodologies for
testosterone analysis and finally we
will discuss current practice guidelines
and recommendations on testosterone
testing blood three so what is
testosterone
well testosterone is a steroid hormone
it is responsible for stimulating
development on male secondary sexual
characteristics it is produced primarily
in the testes in men however it is also
produced in ovaries in women as well as
adrenal cortex at the lower levels the
function of testosterone in women is not
very clear like number four is the
structure of testosterone this made of
four rings one five carbon rings and the
three six carbon rings it contains a
kettle and a hydroxy group at the number
3 and 17 positions respectively like
fire
this latitude the pathway of
testosterone biosynthesis it can be
converted from hi and just in do by 3
beta hydroxy steroid at the hydrogenous
there - 5 4 as murres all 3 beta HSD
they can also be generated from unjust
indium by 17 beta hydroxy steroids the
hydrogenous or 17 beta
HSD by number 6 testosterone is
metabolized to add activity active
steroid hormones such as a sodium and I
hydro testosterone as well as a negative
or weekly active Andrew and just Ron and
eighty college Newland have 7 up 98% of
a total test run in serum is putting
bound and the 2% is free in both men and
women
however most testosterone in male is
weakly bound to albumin while the
majority of tests on you female is bound
to sex hormone-binding globulin flat 8
suppose abdomen bound testosterone and
the free testosterone are biologically
active they are collectively called
bio-available testosterone by 9
clinically testosterone test is used for
evaluation of man with possible type of
gamma disease such as loss libido
erectile dysfunction etc and women with
concert ISM visualization
and illegal malaria all possible tests
or strong efficiency in children it is
primarily used for boys with the delayed
or precocious puberty and infants with
ambiguous genitalia or validation by ten
per patients on testosterone replacement
therapy due to testosterone deficiency
or on anti-androgen therapy such as
prostate cancer precursors to puberty
video Pathak hirsutism and male to
female transgender tested tested on
testing is useful for therapeutic
monitoring in addition testosterone can
be used to diagnose energy secreting
tumor right xi hypogonadism is also
known as testosterone deficiency
syndrome there is a clinical and about
chemical syndrome associated with man
with the benzene agent those patients
have decreased serum testosterone levels
and that they may or may not have a
decrease in tissue sensitivity to
testosterone like 12 president is due to
increased testosterone levels causing
excessive with terminal hair growth in
energy dependent areas of body in women
polycystic ovarian syndrome and
idiopathic - androgen emia are two
common causes of classicism the writer
polycystic ovarian syndrome is a
condition in which the woman the woman's
sex hormones are out of balance the
usually happens among women of
reproductive age they may have in
frequent or prolonged menstrual periods
or elevated testosterone this Beach to
the growth of many small follicles and
fail to regularly release eggs the exact
cause of PCOS is unclear slide 14 so how
to diagnose PCOS in 2003 the Rotterdam
consensus conference was held and the
Rotterdam criteria were proposed they
are three criteria including OAH a and P
Co em all a means illegal and all
revelation H aim is clinical and all
biochemical science of hyper androgynous
I Eve includes the increased serum
testosterone levels TCL M stands for
polycystic ovarian morphology and
exclusion of other ideologies if two out
of three criteria are made the PCOS
diagnosis can be made although it's
fundamental principle is d valid each
over three items needs to be updated
another biomarker the serum
anti-mullerian hormone is a seems
increasingly to be an excellent
substitute for for legal accounts and is
likely to emerge as the official tcon
marker by 50
idiopathic hyper androgyny Mia is
different from T cos because those women
have normal menses normal morphology of
ovaries but they have increased
testosterone levels without other
explanations okay I have introduced the
pathophysiology of testosterone now I
will introduce methodologies of
testosterone testing which include
really immunity amino chemiluminescence
a is a GC mass spectrometry and LC
tandem mass spectrometry
3417 this riddle image that is not
commonly used now I will not talk more
about it all the time automated immunity
my nomination they say is widely used in
hospital labs because it's easily
available does not need instruction
operation in the yearly with quick
turnaround time and high throughput
however compared to other methods its
sensitivity accuracy and precision and
not sufficient particularly at a lower
testosterone levels so it is not
recommended for women and children also
that may have across reactions with
other steroids and there's a significant
variability between different platforms
but 18 this mass spectrometry can
provide multiple steroids screening in
addition to testosterone the sensitivity
specificity and the accuracy are
excellent however the usually needs more
specimen volume and the derivative
nation additionally it is more time
consuming and it is a method with high
complex
but 19 LC tandem mass has become an
attractive method due to its high
sensitivity specificity accuracy and the
less specimen warning than GCMs although
it has a limitations including specimen
extraction high complexity need of
special technical expertise solving the
disposal and the potential metric see
effects like 20 due to its popularity
now I will talk more about this method
the first step of LC tandem mass is
sample preparation many methods are
available including protein
precipitation liquid the liquid
extraction supported a liquid extraction
and a solid phase extraction for example
you can use acetone rgo to precipitate
proteins many solvents can be used for
liquid liquid extraction for instance
dichloromethane a to acetate methyl
tert-butyl either hexane etc supported a
liquor instruction is to use titled
measures earth support to immobilize the
egg we assemble also many Stoli the face
interaction devices are commercially
available such as columns and place you
can do either online or offline
extraction like 21
reverse the face columns are preferred
for testosterone testing you could
select given the particle size and
column size like 22 the mobile phase
include the include could be the mobile
phase could be water with either
methanol or acetone Nigeria or mixture
of these two like 23 mine invasion
method could be electrospray ionization
or atmospheric pressure chemical
ionization with either positive or
negative mode the mass-to-charge ratio
of testosterone to 89 and it has to
product is its mass to charge ratios of
97 and 109 respectively
right 24 internal standard could be
generated a testosterone or 613 labeled
testosterone here are their iron
conditions respectively right 24 this
delicious the chromatogram of
testosterone and other steroids in a
method developed in our lab other you
can see here testosterone can be
separated from other steroid hormones
like 26 here is the
spectrum of testosterone and its product
ions the measured mass-to-charge of
ratios are twenty nine point two well
9.1 and 97.1 respectively but at 27 will
you see 13 labeled testosterone as the
internal standard here is the mass
spectrum of the internal standard and
its product aren't with with mass charge
ratios - net 292 point two and one
hundred twelve point one respectively
right twenty-eight
here is the calibration curve of our
method with analytical measurement to
range of two point five nine one veneer
to 1600 and any one per deal twenty-nine
clinically we could make a total free
and bioavailable testosterone next I
will introduce them individually to
write 30 the measurement of testosterone
is relatively easy less expensive and
widely available both of the
concentration of a to detest wrong is
affected but the concentration of the
total testosterone is affected by many
factors that a change in the amount of
sex hormone-binding globulin and
argument for example aging
hyperthyroidism liver and kidney
diseases also compared to free and
available testosterone the less costly
or closely reflects the levels of and
Jojen ism in an individual
there is a significant Intermezzo of
variability like 31 to reduce the
internet variability CDC has developed a
total testosterone standardization
program testing laboratory will compare
their results with the CDC recently
proven method without to estimate the
bias by testing the single unit fresh
frozen serum symbols the bias limit is
plus minus 6.4 percent that 32
regarding free testosterone there are
several ways to measure it which include
equilibrium dialysis ultra filtration
analog analysis calculation based on sex
hormone-binding model and abdomen 33 you
can do indirect or direct equilibrium
dialysis to separate free testosterone
but 34 this lattice used the process of
indirect method football major total
testosterone in assemble men add a
certain amount of radio labeled
testosterone to the sample a part of a
radio labeled testosterone will bind to
the binding proteins after dialysis
measure the total radioactive
radioactivity and very activity in
lysate respectively
finally use this equation to calculate
free testosterone plus 35
director method is relatively simple you
do not need a radio label of
testosterone after dialysis you can
directly measure testosterone in dialect
which represents free testosterone
however you have to use a very sensitive
method to measure it because the
concentration is very low like 36 the
limitations of equilibrium dialysis
include long time for dialysis and
assemble dilution also fluctuation
fluctuations of pH and the temperature
affect the results right 37 the the
second method is out of filtration this
is an auto filtration device and there
is a membrane in it after loading
assemble the device is centrifuged the
free testosterone will pass through the
membrane and will be collected in the
outer filtrate and the protein bound
testosterone will be retained in central
reservoir lat 38 again temperature
fluctuation has an impact on the
filtration also pretest rolls free
testosterone may be resorted to the
membrane sometimes proteins may leak
from the membrane but 39 analog even
they say is the method using a radio
label testosterone analog to computer
with endogenous free testosterone in
serum for a limited number of and in
testosterone antibody
it is assumed that the analog has a
little affinity for sex hormone-binding
globulin and abdomen but this may not be
true so the analytical performance of
this method is poor and the result
correlated with to do but not read head
sodium levels therefore this method
should not be used due to very limited
clinical utility like 43 testosterone
concentration may be calculated based on
sex hormone-binding globulin and total
testosterone concentrations here is one
of the equation that have been published
most of these equations assume that the
albumin concentration is fixed at 43 or
40 gram per liter right 41 there are two
ways to measure power available
testosterone one is to use 50 percent
ammonia sulfate to precipitate a sex
hormone-binding other to that so that
the testosterone bound to this protein
is removed and the remaining
testosterone is bioavailable it can also
be calculated based on total
testosterone and sex hormone binding
protein with or without abdomen here is
an example of equations like for it
okay I have introduced if it approaches
for testosterone testing the next
question is how to select them several
professional organizations have
developed guidelines to address this
question in 2010 The Endocrine Society
published the clinical guidelines for
testosterone therapy in men with
androgen deficiency syndrome it
recommends a morning total testosterone
testing using a reliable method as the
initial test if it is abnormal repeat
the test to confirm if a result is close
to the lower limit of the reference
range 300 bioavailable testosterone
should be measured to rule out low sex
hormone-binding globulin like 43 the end
open society also published a position
statement in 2007 about testosterone
testing the states that directly mean
Oasis cannot accurately measure the low
serum testosterone levels in women
children and men with testosterone
deficiency it recommends using method
with attraction and purification before
measurement for example LCA tandem mass
spectrometry method the also recommends
calculator free testosterone as a marker
for women with eliwood elevated to the
testosterone like 44 in
fifteen Canadian men's health foundation
published a clinical practice guideline
for diagnosis and management of
testosterone deficiency syndrome in men
it also recommends total testosterone as
the initial test when a patient has
critically low total testosterone
bioavailable of free testosterone is
recommended calculated a free or
bioavailable testosterone should be used
for those men with symptoms and you
critically low have put testosterone
levels like 45 it is recommended to
measure testosterone between 7 and 11
a.m. but those shift of workers it
should be measured within three hour
after waking the testing methods should
be traceable to internationally
recognized vendor standardize the
reference materials and certified by the
CDC than evaluation program ok
like 46 I have introduced the
pathophysiology analysis and the
clinical guidelines of testosterone
testing before I complete my talk I
would like to thank my colleagues Chris
and Cree and a Chris and the team for
their excellent technical support and
for providing the data finally thank you
for your attention if you have any
questions please add me thank you thank
you dr. sue for your presentation a
quick reminder for our audience on how
to submit questions simply type them in
the Q&A box by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation doctors who will answer as
many questions as time permits and any
questions that are not answered will be
answered via email after the
presentation for our first question
we have many hospital labs do not have
mass spectrometers how should they not
measure testosterone for children and
women this is a great question yes many
clinical labs currently do not have mass
spectrometers we know immunoassay are
not reliable for testosterone testing in
children and women so for those patients
they could send samples to reference
labs that use LC tandem mass to measure
testosterone okay thank you
our next question we have is should
deuterated or c-13 labeled testosterone
be used as internal standard for lc-ms
or ms si for testosterone testing
according to the literature are both
deuterated
and assist 13 labeled testosterone can
be used at the internal standard for
testosterone testing
if you use LC 10ml some people may think
assisted c-13 labor internal standard is
more stable but crinkly on both of them
can be used okay great next question
why are Radio immunoassays not commonly
used now because really mean and they
say is the odor to a safe or
testosterone testing because we have to
use Radio isotopes but most the
laboratory try to avoid the Union using
video isotopes also most human races are
labor intensive that's why it is not
commonly used and now most of that they
use amid okay me illuminating the AC
automated raising okay thank you
next question why do you different
testosterone immunoassays generate
variable results that's a great question
um because different the companies use
different anybody's in there
testosterone is also their calibrators
make me different so if you use given
elimination to come from different
companies they may give you variable
results so you have to use a reference
range provided by the specific vendor to
determine your patients result it's
normal or abnormal okay next question
testosterone has two ion transitions
109 and 97 which ion should be used as
quantifier actually both of them can be
used as a quantifier and both of them
have been used but you can use one as a
County Fair and use the other for the
qualifier okay
looks like we have time for one more
question if a male patient has slightly
low testosterone does this mean the
patient has testosterone deficiency this
very good question um the patient of
maintenance or testosterone deficiency
because this could be caused by decrease
in sex hormone binding protein binding
cuddlin and all arguments to answer your
question you have to measure free or
bioavailable testosterone for
conformation okay thank you I would like
to once again thank dr. drew for his
presentation and I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today will be
addressed by the speaker via email after
the presentation we would like to thank
our educational sponsor agilent
technologies for today's webcast this
webcast can be vail viewed on-demand
through January of 2018 lab routes will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that you know with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event until
next time goodbye